le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères a donc donné sa conférence de
presse annuelle tout à l'heure il a
répondu aux questions des journalistes
présents dans la salle ou encore par
visioconférence il a fait le bilan de
l'année écoulée on revient sur cette
conférence de presse avec notre
correspondant à moscou antoine gayraud
bonjour antoine que faut-il retenir de
cette conférence de presse
le bien pendant 2h30 sergueï lavrov a
évoqué de très nombreux sujets en lien
avec les événements qui font l'actualité
qui ont fait l'actualité tout au long de
l'année 2020 l'ukraine a bien entendu
été sujette à de nombreuses questions ce
qui a permis au ministre russe des
affaires étrangères de rappeler les
lignes rouges à ne pas franchir mais
aussi des activités qui ont lieu sur le
territoire ukrainien et sur lesquels
l'occident détourne le regard écoutez
nous sommes catégoriquement contre
la présence de le temps à côté de notre
frontière y compris compte tenu du cap
menée par les autorités ukrainiennes je
parle des autorités présidente et des
autorités d'aujourd'hui malheureusement
de plus c'est une vraie ligne rouge
et ils s'en rendent compte ensuite elle
deuxièmement si l'ukraine n'est pas
membre de le temps on pourrait parler
des accords bilatéraux avec les
américains les britanniques et d'autres
pays occidentaux
qui crée des objets militaires qui ouvre
des bases sur la mer d'azov c'est aussi
une situation inacceptable pour nous
on l'a constaté cette semaine des
représentants russes se sont entretenus
avec des représentants américains des
représentants de l'otan ou encore de
l'eau et se met pas de dialogue direct
avec l'union européenne et pourtant il
est question de la stabilité stratégique
et sécuritaire du continent européen
sergueï lavrov nous explique pourquoi
en ce qui nous concerne ne sont pas très
préoccupé par le fait qui participera
dans les négociations
oui les états unis ont pu
renouveler
leur rôle prépondérant sur le continent
européen
grâce à le temps
il mène
la politique qui vise à harmoniser
toutes les actions
qui prévoit des questions militaires
entre le temps et l'union européenne
pour terminer avec josep borrell nous
avons parlé avec lui en marge
du conseil des ministres de l'est cae à
stockholm en fait tout cela dépendra du
fait et ce qu'ils on lui permettra de
renouveler le dialogue avec la russie
est-ce que les leurs questions seront
constructives
toujours à propos des garanties de
sécurité demandées par la russie le
ministre des affaires étrangères a
souligné que le proposition russe
n'était pas un menu dans lequel on
pouvait juste choisir une ou deux
mesures mais plutôt un ensemble un
paquet de mesures à part entière cette
conférence de presse aura donc été le
très dense de très nombreux sujets ont
été évoqués les relations entre la
russie et de nombreux pays comme alors
sans tous les citer mais l'inde la chine
ou encore les états unis bien entendu
sergueï lavrov a ainsi pu donner la
couleur sur la fermeté de la position
russe à propos de la demande de gages
sérieux et écrits concernant l'arrêt de
l'expansion de l'otan et de ses
activités aux frontières de la russie
merci beaucoup antoine gayraud pour
toutes ces précisions sur cette
conférence de presse du ministre russe
des affaires étrangères merci à vous